في اليوم الذي رفعت فيه اللجنة الفيدرالية لسعر الفائدة في سياستها بمقدار نصف نقطة مئوية ، وتتوقع أن الزيادات المستمرة في المعدل المستهدف لسعر الأموال الفيدرالية ستكون مناسبة للتضخم مرتفعًا للغاية ونحن نتفهم الصعوبات التي يسببها ونحن نتحرك بسرعة إلى قم بإعادته إلى أسفل ، لدينا كل من الأدوات التي نحتاجها والعزم الذي يتطلبه الأمر لاستعادة استقرار الأسعار [موسيقى] هذا هو أننا لدينا جائحة لدينا أعلى معدل بطالة منذ فترة الكساد ، ثم لدينا هذه الاستجابة الضخمة من السياسة المالية والسياسة النقدية ، ثم لدينا تضخم ولدينا حرب في أوكرانيا والتي تقطع السلعة [الموسيقى] [الموسيقى] ما يأملون في تحقيقه هو هندسة هبوط ناعم من خلال هذا أعني ما رأيناه في عام 1994 ، سبعة زيادات في المعدلات في 13 شهرًا لم تدفع بالاقتصاد إلى الركود بل تسببت في تباطؤه ، وهذا ما يأملون في القيام به هذه المرة أيضًا.